if we have two groups and in each group
I have four so that's one group of four
and then here's my second group of four
we already know that we could write this
as two we could write this as 2 times 2
times 4 which is the same thing which is
the same thing as 4 plus 4 notice I have
two fours here I have 4 plus another 4
which is going to be equal to well if I
have 4 plus 4 or if I have 2 groups of 4
either way I'm going to have a total of
8 things and you see that right over
here we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 things what
I want you to do is pause the video now
and try to group these same 8 things but
to droop it in other ways so that you
can represent 8 as the product of whole
numbers here I've represented 8 as the
product of 2 & 4 2 times 4 is 8
see if you can represent 8 as the
product of other whole numbers or as
whole numbers in different ways grouping
it in different ways so I assume you've
paused the video so let's try it out
ourselves
so one thing we could do we could view
this instead of as two groups of four we
can view 8 as four groups of two so
that's one group of two two groups of
two three groups of two four groups of
two so we could write down we could
write that 4 times 2 4 times 2 is equal
to 8 and we could view this is the same
thing it's literally four twos we have
one two three four twos each of these
have two in them so we're going to say 1
2 3 4 2 s 2 plus 2 plus 2 plus 2 is
equal to 8 these are both equivalent 4
times 2 literally 4 groups of 2 that's
the same thing as taking four twos and
adding them together notice we have two
twos right over here
we added them together one two here we
have four twos and we are adding them
together one two three four we take our
four twos and we add them together how
else could we represent eight
well we literally could view it as eight
groups of one so let's do that so eight
groups of one would look like this
that's one group of one two three four
five six seven eight so we could write
this down as 8 times 1 eight times one
is once again equal to eight and if we
wanted to write this down as repeated
addition well this is the reate ones so
1 plus 1 plus 1 plus 1 plus 1 plus 1
let's see this one two three four five
six seven eight one two three four five
six seven eight one plus one plus one
plus one plus one plus one plus one plus
one is equal to eight now you might be a
little stumped well what's another way
of getting to eight well you could
literally view it as one group of eight
one group of eight so let me do it that
way so this is just one one entire group
of eight the whole thing the whole thing
is a group of eight so we could write
this down as one let me scroll over to
the right a little bit we could write
this down as one times 8 and one times
eight is equal to eight and how would we
view that well we're not at we only have
one eight now we don't have to add that
one eight to anything else so we could
literally write this down if we wanted
to to do it the way we've done the last
few we could literally write it down so
it's just we just have one eight well
one eight is clearly going to just be
equal to eight so now let me ask you
another question so far we've been
focused on each of these groups but what
if we actually view this as four groups
of eight so what if we actually viewed
it as let me let me clear this what if
we actually viewed this as four groups
of eight then how many things are we
actually going to have so let me make
this very clear so we have one group of
eight two groups of eight three groups
of eight and four four groups of eight
so we would view this as four times four
times 8 or which is going to be the same
thing as eight eight plus eight plus
eight plus eight for eight what is this
going to be equal to and I encourage you
to pause the video and figure it out
right now well there's a couple of ways
that you could have thought about this
you could have just literally just
counted these or you could say well
let's see eight you could skip count by
eight 8 16 24 32 or you could have said
8 plus 8 is 16 plus 8 is 24 plus 8 is 32
or you could have literally just counted
the triangles here